- Growing up they tell us being gay,
you go to hell.
When my father put my arm
to the flame, he told me,
"This is what it feels
for 5 seconds.
Imagine eternity."
-Action.
-We can all relate to someone
who is coming from a small town
who is not able
to be himself.
-I play Zain.
He helps Rafiq
discover a new
way to live his life.
- Are you not afraid
people will find out?
- Of course, I'm scared.
That's why I'm going to America.
I'm going to be
a Hollywood star.
- Rafiq needs to
leave the Middle East.
He is not safe because of
his sexual orientation,
and he needs to seek asylum.
So many people across the world
have struggled so much
to find a place
where they can be themselves,
and more than that, to, like,
know that they can be loved.
- When it comes to artist rights
in Syria, they are persecuted,
especially when they approach
any freedom issues.
I believe that this project
comes as a response.
This is the first show about
LGBTQ rights in Syria,
and it opens a new conversation.
- It's very important for us to
give this story justice
so that everyone who sees it
will be very moved,
and hopefully changed.